that night you guys were amongst the
first responder
I don't know you've been called Heroes
you've been called Saints you've been
called Angels
um and you guys showed up to work to do
your job just like any other night
um what was it like
in that moment
yeah you know I think what I think one
of the big unique things of that night
is typically in our world when we when
we train one of the first things that we
we just preach and constantly dwell into
our crew's head is seeing safety we
don't enter unsafe scenes that's not our
job that is not our role that's what law
enforcement is for and it's not until
law enforcement gives the all clear or
some level of it being clear that then
we begin to move crews in and go to work
what was unique that night was we had
been contracted to provide medical
services for for the festival and we we
had a
we had a duty and obligation a want to
to begin responding from within and
that's what we did you know the the
countless stories of just our Personnel
that were assigned to the event those
that work for us that
um you know that night they were there
to enjoy the concert and like
like anybody they had the opportunity to
get out of there and they chose to stay
behind I don't know how you put into
words what
one what that makes you feel like as
somebody who was tasked with leading
this group and and two how you just put
that into words that
you have the opportunity to be
surrounded and work with people at our
so focused on helping others
um like any large scale event that we do
we have Crews that are strategically
placed throughout the venue we're at the
point now in the event where the main
Act is on the stage so naturally that's
where the crowd is the crowd is focused
on that main stage any other activation
has been shut down and so crews are
strategically placed one end of the the
venue we have a large medical tent that
seeing patients you know for for various
things whether that's you know blisters
Cuts I had a little too much to drink
tonight whatever that may be and so
business as usual
me in particular I was helping some
guests of the concert into a cab and so
at the moment just before we heard the
first volley I was putting two guests
into a taxi cab that then would head
Northbound on the strip for me at that
moment it was me turning around
at that point I was I was I was about
ready to call it a day myself it had
been long weekend the crews were in
place the crews were doing what they
needed to do there was not necessarily a
need for me to be there and my vehicle
was was parked
more or less behind the venue but
walking South and so as I turned around
and began that walk that's when we heard
what was the first volley not realizing
that's what it was and trying to figure
out exactly what was going on I'm
surrounded by you know other Metro
officers and everyone's kind of looking
up looking down looking right looking
left trying to figure out what's going
on and that's when you know law
enforcement began to take cover behind a
wall that separates the the street from
the sidewalk on Las Vegas Boulevard
naturally I I followed suit and took
cover behind that wall that's when you
quickly realized that this wasn't
this wasn't crackling power lines this
wasn't
this wasn't some sort of drive-by this
wasn't any scenario you would you could
fathom this was shots were being fired
in our Direction
and for me the you know again going back
to you know we teach scene safety we
also teach crew safety you know if we're
not if we're not safe or if we get
injured then we're no help to to those
that need our help but on the flip side
there was for me
16 of my co-workers that were inside 16
people that I played a part in assigning
to this event that
I felt
I have a responsibility for when we go
and work these events you know we do
briefings we don't talk about
you know let's let's all make sure that
we get home safe tonight it's not it's
not a normal part of briefing but
there's that underlying
responsibility that you have as a leader
to to make sure that
that we leave the same way that we
arrived and in those moments that became
a very real reality that
this is bad something's happening
there's going to be a lot of people
coming our way really fast and this is
what we
want to say this is what we train for
but this is what we talk about this is
it this is this is the big one
um
and so for me it was it never crossed my
mind that I needed to get out of there
what crossed my mind was I need to find
my people
um I need to
we need to group together we need to
come up with a plan and we need to get
out there and go to work
little did I know our teams were already
going to work they were grabbing people
they're pulling people underneath the
stage they were they were beginning that
evacuation moment
um I can only imagine what was going
through their mind you know through my
mind you everything from
or my co-workers safe I probably should
try to call my family real quick I
should write just a laundry list of
what's going on what's happening right
now all the while not knowing where not
knowing where the bullets are coming
from but just constantly hearing bullets
uh you know from hearing bullets to the
next thing you do is you can you can
smell burning flesh from people that had
you know either been grazed by a bullet
or been shot by a bullet you begin
journeying through the venue trying to
get to you know for me my my end point
was our medical tent and you look right
you look left and there's people that
are there's people that are dead
um there's there's a there's an urgency
in the crowd of people that don't want
to leave
they want to help they want it to do
whatever they could to be an extension
of us
there were throughout the night through
in those immediate moments there were
patients being brought to us
there were bystanders that had some
clearly had some knowledge of of
medicine asking you know we need to
start CPR on this girl
when you start CPR on this this kid
um and that and that you know some of
those are images that'll never leave my
mind
um even just talking about it right now
I can I can picture two of the 58 that
lost their lives that night that died
there
um and having to look somebody in the
face asking you to do CPR on somebody
and Point Blank saying no we're not
going to do that tonight
you know it's it's easy to say that we
talk about that in a in a training
session and how we're going to manage a
mass casualty incident and what our what
our triage and what our treatment is
going to look like that night and it's
easy to take a test and answer those
questions but then to to be faced with
in part what is a a note to me a
no-brainer right can you do CPR on this
person well I'm a you know it's what
what seemed to be such a simple question
to have to tell somebody no
um is
the right decision
um but it's certainly you know something
that still
uh in this moment just
I think it bothers me to some extent
um you know sights and sounds that
uh
uh I had never experienced in my career
or were experienced in those moments
I've run calls where people have been
shot I've run calls where multiple
people have been shot but to have
pure chaos
a patient walk up to me who had
had taken a bullet to the top of her
skull having a vivid conversation with
me trying to figure out why the top of
her head is burning
and just just how quick those moments
were but at the same time how fast all
this was happening
yeah I mean it's
it's
hard to describe how you
I don't know if there's a way you sum up
everything that you saw that night or
everything that you experienced or
everything that you felt in in that
moment and and Beyond those immediate
minutes of of gunfire
just amongst all the chaos that was
happening that night to see people that
took objects that were never meant to be
backboards objects devices that were
never meant to move people to see people
just go to work and to bring patients to
us at
to me those are the heroes
I was assigned to be there that night
I didn't pay to go there
these people paid to go there these fans
paid to be there they paid for an
experience and
um they had like many they had the
opportunity to to evacuate and get out
of there get out of Harm's Way and they
didn't and some didn't until you more or
less had to force them to leave
that's that's heroism
um
I think there was a bond that's that's
you know that that's been created really
amongst our community when it comes to
the EMS community
I think there's you know moments where
you know the people that were there that
night and the people that responded that
night
um you know there's a moment where the
first ambulance showed up
and it had been what felt like an
eternity for ambulances to show up and
in our world when resources aren't
showing up it's because the scene's not
safe
and so hearing the sirens in the
distance thinking to yourself these
resources are going to be held back
and then all of a sudden that resource
shows up that ambulance shows up and
there is no hesitation from that crew
that they look you in the eyes you make
eye contact and you immediately know
that
we're working we're going to work we got
to get this done and to hear words from
fellow colleagues saying put as many as
you can back here
is that something that would happen on a
day-to-day basis
yeah I think so
um
you know typically when you call 9-1-1
and ambulance responds there may be one
patient and maybe two patients any more
than that more ambulances come and take
those one or two patients but
to take as many critical patients at
this particular crew took that night
that for me was a
that was a defining moment of that night
um
I think that night for me overall and
the days that followed
as a as a kid I always had a passion for
medicine I always wanted to to do
something medicine related I had dreams
of being a doctor of you know whatever
that looked like
um but I always thought it'd be cool to
be an ambulance how cool would it be to
drive up and down the strip with lights
and sirens on like how cool would that
be and so straight out of high school
was given that opportunity
and over the years you know my
what I saw myself doing in medicine
shifted
um whether that was to to go to medical
school those thoughts shifted those
thoughts changed I second guessed it I
you know reconsidered it but one thing
that never changed and one thing that
for me was solidified that night
was that
I have been placed where I'm at to help
people and that night solidified that
whatever I do in my life I want to help
people and whether that's through
medicine whether that's through you name
it
I want to be there for people when it's
their moment when they're at what they
believe is the lowest of low in their
their time of need I want to be that
person and for me it's given me a drive
to explore how how do we how do we
better serve our community how do I
better serve my community
that that moment solidified that
and I'm constantly reminded of that
every time I see a sticker that says
Vegas strong
and you know unfortunately I think
things happen in our society that
various hashtags are created various
phrases are created
and growing up here in southern Nevada
there's
a lot of people don't realize that
there's Community outside of
the glitz the glamor the entertainment
the amazing stuff that our city does but
there is such a community here
it's a community that I've been
fortunate to grow up in it's a community
that I've attended College in it's a
community that I've been given the
opportunity to be able to give back in
that Vegas strong just for me as cliche
as it sounds has such a significant
meaning
for me it's an even more significant
meaning that I have an opportunity to
work at a company called community
to be able to serve my community
in the days and weeks that followed how
did you
take care of yourselves
yeah you know uh
believe it or not you'll meet a lot of
type a person Personalities in this
business
people that don't want help
people that are more worried about
everyone else besides themselves
and one of the things that makes me
proud to be able to work for this
organization was that from the moment
that this occurred to the that morning
following the hours long that we were on
that scene
we brought in counselors we brought in
therapists
and
I can tell you that you know it's uh
EMS doesn't have it figured out First
Responders don't have it figured out
but I can tell you that this company did
everything it could
to
ensure that mental health and the
well-being of all of our employees was
taken care of
I think it's something we still struggle
with today
it's a
you know unfortunately we still continue
to lose people to to mental health
issues in our industry
um
and We Know It Takes a toll on on our
personnel
you know for me personally it took a
while it took a while to crack the crack
the shell for me to open up and to be
able to share
and to be able to figure out why I was
having the thoughts I was having or or
having the visions that I was having
um
but yeah there's a
it's a focus of ours it's it's something
that we deeply care about here in our
organization and you know we we
constantly try to find ways and whether
they be subtle whether they be more
direct to really focus in on the mental
health and the mental well-being of not
only our leaders but of our
men and women that every day don't know
what they're going to respond to don't
know what they're going to experience
and
and truth be told don't know if they're
gonna
make it home that night
in the five years since
what has changed for the better
um
you know I think there's a you know five
years later I think there's
there's a handful of things that have
changed I think from a from an industry
standpoint
um there's a little bit
I think there's more emphasis to have
the uncomfortable conversations
um being the entertainment capital of
the world we attract a lot we attract
big events and
When We Gather in a room with ourselves
with stakeholders and Community Partners
um you're now in a room where we can
have those difficult conversations
nobody wants to talk about what happens
if there's a bomb what happens if
there's this device what happens if
somebody decides to to do something bad
and some of them are I think easier to
talk about as opposed to others
I think there's this underlying
I don't think I know you know in our
world in that first responder world
there's lots of conversation about
what's going to happen next
not if it's going to happen but when is
it going to happen and so I think
there's a you know there's a more
emphasis from from the industry from
from what we're doing to ensure that the
safety of all the of all those that live
here visit here and go to these events
because
at the end of the day
um
evil is not going to Prevail five years
later evil has not prevailed there's
been some challenging things that have
happened in our communities some bad
things that have happened in our
community but I think five years later
we're still
we're still this tight-knit community
we're still here to look out for one
another
we're still we're still Vegas strong
personally what's changed
you know up until up until a week ago it
was it's
still trying to wrap my my head around
that it's been five years
it's you know it's
it's
difficult
it's you know lots of reflection you
know that night unfortunately I lost a
friend who's amongst the one of the 58
at that passed
and and those thoughts come back
this year was the first year that
I went back through text messages that I
had from five years ago everything from
people that were checking in on me to
the text that I sent to to my family
to the text that I sent to to somebody
that died
and that was the first time in in the
five years I'm sure I looked at them you
know post post the event but probably
the first time that kind of stirred
these emotions at
you know
in those
I think we have a tendency to
compartmentalize where we put feelings
and where our emotions are stored and
for me five years later it kind of it's
opened up some of those but for me it
again it reminds me of the community
that I'm a part of it reminds me of the
opportunity I have to be able to do what
I do to be able to sit down and be able
to share
my story to be able to share the story
of the hundreds and thousands of people
in our community that helped that night
for those that are complete strangers to
our community that every year they come
back
um and want to
they're part of this unique Community
that's that's been created after such a
horrific event
I mean our communities
stood up for the
the minutes and the hours and the days
and the weeks and the years since that
event there was a
there was a it was a it was a different
and it still is there was almost a turn
um you know for for somebody you know
walking into a Starbucks in uniform
somebody holding the door open for you
and just saying thank you
um you know it's it's uh it's easy for
me to thank people
um but when people were thinking me it
was
maybe to this day it's hard
um you know and I don't I don't stand
behind the
um what's what you're paid to do it's
it's what you signed up for
nobody that wears our uniform signed up
for that night nobody that wears our
uniform signs up to get shot at nobody
signs up for this career to to deal with
demons and have nightmares is it a part
of the job it's become part of the job
but
um yeah the community has really showed
up that night and you know it's I think
it's just important that
we have these difficult conversations
um you know stop the bleed training
where we teach people how to put
tourniquets on and how you can
truly save somebody's life those are
tools that came out of bad experiences
you know we learn a lot of this stuff
because of war and that's a tool that
you know we used in EMS and it was a
tool that that night was an important
tool and you know a very Vivid thought
that night was seeing folks that would
take blankets that would take
stethoscopes that were taking seat belts
and turning them into tourniquets
because it's such an important tool and
uh yeah I mean I you know our I truly
believe that we're all placed where we
are for a reason
um we have bad things that happen in
life we have a few bad sour apples in
our in our society but we're a community
that is here to look out for one another
and support one another and anything we
can do to to make ourselves better in
turn makes our community that much
stronger